it wasn't until late in the first season
of ncis new orleans that viewers met
atf agent sonja percy played by tony
nominated actress shalita grant
once she became a regular on the show in
season two
she quickly became a favorite thanks to
her penchant for calling out bs
in her great chemistry with agent
christopher lasalle
played by lucas black as anybody who
watches network crime procedures will
tell you
all good things must come to an end and
no ncis agent is forever
after three seasons on the show grant
decided to hand in her badge
and the character of agent percy was
retired any time an actor leaves a hit
show
it always raises the question was there
ouster a natural progression of the
story
or was something going on behind the
scenes coming in with some
attitude let me lighten that load for
you i hate to spoil a party but
we gotta talk throughout the fourth
season of the show
it was clear to the ncis new orleans
team that something was eating at agent
percy
she seemed restless and distracted and
made a few bad calls that were out of
character
in her penultimate episode on the show
welcome to the jungle
percy revealed that she interviewed for
a position with the fbi
her issues it seems were caused by a
nagging feeling that she needed to move
on to something new
although she was offered the fbi job
percy initially declined it
as she didn't want to upset her ncis
squad mates
in percy's final episode high stakes she
and agent lasalle were assigned to work
a sting operation at a poker game
percy ended up in an suv with the perp
they were tracking
and in a split second decision she
rolled the vehicle to prevent him from
getting the upper hand on her it was a
very risky move that ended up paying off
but it was further proof that percy's
instincts were being affected by her
feeling of restlessness
in the end percy realized that the only
reason she turned down the fbi job
was to avoid disappointing other people
which wasn't the correct decision to
make for herself
at the end of the episode she announced
her departure from the team when variety
originally reported on grant's decision
to leave
they cited sources who said the
departure is amicable and mutually
agreed upon
between the actress and the producers in
a later report on deadline
the actress herself claimed she was
ready to move on the year after exiting
the show
grant landed a recurring role on the
final season of santa clarita diet
good afternoon everyone i'm special
agent tess rogers with the fbi
in 2017 while grant was still on ncis
new orleans
she did open up about the difficulties
of transitioning from theater to the
world of primetime crime dramas in an
interview with lenny letter
grant said i didn't realize just how
different a procedural is
i do come from theater and i am always
looking for ways to be human and be
alive and in the moment
it is challenging to do that with a
procedural she's far from the first
actor to speak up about the grind of
filming 22 episode seasons
although she didn't cite those
particular issues when speaking about
her exit
it seems likely that they played a role
in her decision to move on to different
projects
one of those different projects may also
shine some light on what factors
motivated her to leave the show
it wasn't just her role on santa clarita
diet that kept graham busy after she
left ncis new orleans
the enterprising actress launched a
haircare line specifically for black
women with
type 4 hair called four naturals on the
company's website grant opened up about
what inspired her to launch her hair
care line
she said i found myself utterly wrecked
after three years on a television show
that decimated my natural hair and my
self-image
my tight type 4 hair was not welcome
instead
the producers and hair department had no
issue with my natural hair suffering or
falling out to comply with the mandate
to wear a ponytail with little to no
curl after quitting what was once a
dream job i told myself that i would
turn that pain into a platform
although she didn't specify which show
caused the damage
ncis new orleans is the actress's only
three year long stint on any series
it seems likely that it's the culprit
and it seems this difficult environment
could be another reason grant decided to
leave
i'm going to miss you city mouse
i'll miss you too country mouse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one